it is going from bad to worse for Donald
Trump we already know about Trump's
business connections to Russia that go
back decades when talking to a magazine
in 2013 about a meeting he had in Moscow
with potential investors Donald Trump
said two real-estate weekly quote I have
a great relationship with many Russians
and almost all of the oligarchs were in
the room
in 2008 Donald Trump jr. spoke at a real
estate conference and said quote
Russians make up a pretty
disproportionate cross-section of a lot
of our assets USA Today has done a
review which reveals that not only have
Trump and his companies done significant
business with Russia over the years but
that they've been tied to at least 10
former Soviet businessmen with alleged
links to organized crime and money
laundering these are what we would
colloquially call mobsters three owners
of Trump brand condos in Florida and New
York were federally indicted for illegal
gambling and money laundering activities
associated with the Russian mafia a
Ukrainian who owned two Trump condos in
Florida was indicted in a
money-laundering scheme involving a
former Prime Minister of Ukraine a
member of the firm that developed
Trump's condos in Soho New York is a
Russian immigrant who's a two-time
convicted felon for stabbing a man and
for a 40 million dollar stock
manipulation and money laundering scheme
it's weird because I thought Trump was
against violent immigrants but at the
same time he has violent immigrants as
business partners it's almost like
everything he says is hypocritical or it
just depends on the country of origin
because he's right totally willing to
hire Polish immigrants to work on his
buildings but he seems to be against
Mexican immigrants and wants to build a
wall one of trumps Russian investors in
the Soho project was accused by the
Belgian government of laundering 55
million dollars in 2011 there's a former
Kazakh mayor who was indicted by the US
government in 2014 for using millions of
stolen dollars to buy three of those
Soho condo units the White House was
asked for a comment they have declined
to comment but Sean Spicer you can
always go to Spicer for some kind of
gold he said Trump has never had any
connection connections to Russian crime
well I'm convinced
yes yet another thing that because Sean
Spicer has said it's a non-issue we just
don't have to worry about it anymore
well if you take a look at that Trump
Russia dossier which is of course
sketchy but seemingly more and more gets
confirmed every single week less sketchy
every week yeah that that alleges that
the Trump Putin ties go back to 2011
because it says five years and five
years from when it was released was 2011
and that Putin had been prepping Donald
Trump to run for that entire time so
that timeline would make sense and
there's no doubt whatsoever that Putin
is very intertwined with organized crime
in Russia it's almost difficult to be
involved with Russian politicians and
not Russian organized crime if you were
at all part of the Vladimir Putin sort
of cabal or regime or call it what you
will I'm still actually shocked that
Alex Jones supports Trump because for a
conspiracy theorist there's so much here
right Alex Jones should be doing is
Russian mobsters stuff all the time and
he's not doing it because for whatever
reason he's not alarmed by the actual
imaginary conspiracies Alex Jones is all
over and then he ends up sometimes
having to apologize like he did earlier
this week for the pizza gate stuff this
is a treasure trove of all sorts of
sketchy connections and Alex Jones is
pretending like nothing's going on if
Alex Jones could go back in time I think
he would have denounced Trump earlier on
and would have followed this Russia
investigation and would have been all
over it this does tell us at least
something about why Donald Trump
continues to refuse to release the tax
returns don't you think there must be
something in there that would link him
to I mean at this point we're talking
about dozens and dozens of different
people yeah when he initially wasn't
willing to release his tax returns we
thought it had more to do with the fact
that he wasn't as rich as he claims to
be he's now charitable as he claims to
be oh would I still be true totally yeah
but now he realized it may be something
even more important than that that he
has conflicts of interest is there any
doubt in your mind that if President
Obama had just a fraction of the
scandals that Trump has had so far that
Republicans would be calling for his
head and you would have a dozen
investigations and panels into it
probably yeah people would be calling
for impeachment already which in the
case of Democratic lawmakers hasn't so
far happened to Trump yet I think that
would happen if the
the collusion angle is confirmed you're
probably right yeah I mean Obama did
have that scandal where when he was
talking about something serious one day
he wore its Han suit and you know that
was that was really bad Pat the audacity
of taupe yeah right that's the best I
really like that that is very very
clever okay so anyway Trump connections
to Russian politicians Russian mobsters
Russian hackers indirectly through Roger
stone and his back channels it's not
looking too good